about 80,000 and almost all of it is
specifically student loans I've got
about 5 min left on my car everything
else we own just the student loans of a
big one and how much non retirement
savings do you have um I have about
45,000 cool you can knock out almost
half of it pretty much yeah just I kind
of grown attached to it because it's
taken a lot of it so I figured the
answer is the to just dump it right in
um deep since that is going to knock out
half of it so I should I still pay it
off from smallest to largest or should I
go from interest rate in this case most
largest just knock it out knock off as
many of as you can knock off I mean
what's your largest student loan 24,000
okay so it's still going to be sitting
there what's the second largest one
after that they're all between two and
four thousand just okay so you're going
to have my money you're gonna have a few
ankle-biters left plus the twenty four
thousand after you throw forty five at
it and then you're going to really just
be able to tear into that thing big-time
and it'll change the way you go after
those bonuses because now you got
something to do with them you're gonna
love this and here's the thing here's
the thing we're not we're not getting
rid of the forty five thousand for it to
never come back we're getting rid of it
so you're gonna have more money because
when you don't have any payments
weighing you down you're gonna have
money and that's the whole thing your
most powerful wealth building tool is
your income and it's getting ready to
return to your it's gonna be under your
power again very soon you're gonna get
there I mean you're gonna be out of debt
less than a year you should be with what
you're describing to me this is the Dave
Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]